dana first of all let me ask you
congratulations i mean you made it
through the whole pandemic
moment laid off you kept people employed
um
that's off to you i know a lot of people
are involved but you you made a point to
say we're going to get through this
thing we're going to fight you we're
still going to do that you've
got to be yeah yeah it's definitely it's
definitely the hardest thing that i ever
went through my whole career um
but without a doubt one of the proudest
things you know
to not lay off an employee or i mean if
you look at how massive the nfl is and
how powerful the nfl is
they're on their second round of layoffs
and uh
yeah we haven't laid anybody off and
haven't cut anybody's salaries or
anything like that
we just charge right through it i'm glad
it's over you got the big fight coming
up this weekend sold out t-mobile
packed house will this be one of your
largest pay-per-view games
yeah it's one of the largest gates ever
it's the most pre-buys ever for a fight
um it's just this thing is it's trending
off the charts right now so
and i mean you feel it here in vegas
this weekend you know it's it's
it's it's people are ready to get back
to
having fun i mean you got us
sold out at t-mobile you got garth
brooks sold out at raider stadium
rogan and chappelle sold out mgm grant
garden thursday and friday night
justin bieber sold out at the win and
the list just goes on and on of all the
things that are going on this weekend
and they're all sold out i guess you
just tribute that to people wanting to
get back to their lives and having fun
and doing things and being with people
is that
100 people are done people are done
hiding in their houses and
you know with all the craziness we've
dealt with over the last year and a half
and
and vegas i mean if you look at all the
things that vegas offers as it is
and then this weekend there's no place
on earth that has more entertainment
than what's going on this weekend in
vegas
it's cool how you abu dhabi but then you
went to houston jacksonville
you just kept these fights going but
vegas has always been your kind of
this is the place right well this is our
hometown i mean this is our hometown
this is you know
where we were hoping we could we could
put on a fight first but
we're lucky that we had people that
worked with us through this thing
like abu dhabi florida you know
uh governor desantis was incredible
through this thing
um right when it started we were able to
go there and put on fights without a
crowd
and then we were the first you know to
go indoor arena sold
out packed so then we went jacksonville
houston
arizona and now we're back in vegas
a lot of fans is trump going to be at
the fight he will he'll be at the fight
outside
yeah this is probably the most
celebrities ever
we've ever had an event in 20 years why
is that
it's a big fight and you know a lot of
these guys you know
celebrities are used to going to
whatever is available you know
whatever's going on they can go there
hasn't been anything so
this is like the first real big fight
back and
that i'm telling you man but the ticket
thing has been driving me tickets is the
worst part of this job anyway
all right the worst part of this job the
last two and a half weeks
literally been dealing with tickets
every time i come in my girl amber or
ticket girl is standing at my desk
waiting for me man
i can't shake this ticket thing it just
and it doesn't end
and you know as you get closer to the
event that's when everybody starts
calling
so it's been nuts i was looking on stub
of i think the cheapest was
close to 700 the most expensive into the
thousands i'm just thinking
this has got to be like one of the this
is almost like the mcgregor
connor kind of a deal almost right well
i was just looking
uh it was a couple days ago maybe it was
a week ago
two tickets in the second row sold for
215 000.
215 000 for two tickets
yeah that's crazy yeah i think back to
when
you have so many fighters now that if
they want to fight they fight it they
don't want to fight they don't want to
fight it's all
you're not begging anybody anymore you
got so many
quality fighters that you they're
they're coming right you have to beg
john jones to come out and fire connor
because you've got the staple of so many
great fighters
come on media guys oh is the cameraman
with the phone
was this this guy
ready yep
[Laughter]
um yeah as this thing has grown we are
a global company we have fighters from
all over the world
um you know we put on a lot of fights
too though we're doing 44 fights a year
and uh yeah but but there's never going
to be a position where you know
i've gone out and uh you know i've been
terrorizing habib to come back
uh when cormier wanted to retire i i
would love to have seen him fight a
couple more
but yeah no there's never a situation
where i'm out
he's chasing a guy if you if you want to
fight we got fights every saturday
you see john jones fighting soon he
won't fight this year he said he's going
to fight next year
so when he's ready i'll have a saturday
for him what about what
connor's been a dream come true has he
what's up
conor mcgregor has been an absolute
dream come true for ufc
yeah no the kids you know not just a
superstar for us but
a superstar in global sports um
you know no matter where this kid goes
you know he gets mobbed
and uh fans love them because yes the
answer is yes he's been incredible for
us for the business
and the brand with the olympics coming
up i was just talking to somebody
you have you have boxing and then you
have ufc why wouldn't you put
is it just too difficult to put the uf
to a mixed martial arts
into the olympics should have been done
a long time ago but that's you know
it's not anything that i'm chasing oh i
don't care if it ever happens to be
honest with you
i don't i don't need the olympics yeah
would it be
fun or i mean you just don't care i i
literally could care less
oh yeah it should happen a long time ago
and i'm assuming someday it will
probably happen
you know if the olympic committee ever
smartens up you know
and they want something that's exciting
and actually draws ratings and would
actually sell tickets and
and bring fans then they would do it but
the answer is the olympic community
probably will not
that these guys don't don't make a lot
of smart moves in my in my opinion
and i don't care if it ever happens what
about the the
marijuana use not testing for that now
you don't get banned or penalized and
that
that's well that's a smart move isn't it
yeah i you know we've been
we've been uh advocates of that anyway
so
for it to finally happen is good you
know and and
you know it's good to see nevada leading
the way on that too
let me ask you about the fight this
weekend now you got for the third time
fourier and
conor how just your impressions of that
fight
so what people love are trilogies and
and
you know when you have a guy who's a
superstar like connor and these guys are
one on one and the big question
you know that everybody has for conor
right now is this dude is extremely
wealthy
he has a ton of money does he still have
the desire that that that fire to come
back and
and go after another world title uh you
know if he wins on saturday night
it'll be crazy it'll be huge you know
he'll be next in line
to fight aloe vera for the title and
then poirier
you know was criticized for taking this
fight fourier did the absolute right
thing this guy's been in the sport
forever he's done it all seen it all
you take the money fight especially when
you're the number one ranked guy in the
world it's not like he's ranked number
seven
and he had an opportunity to fight for
the title and he picked conor instead
you know he's number one he's the guy so
yes you take this conor fight you just
beat him
and if you beat him again you get to
beat conor be a part of a huge money
fight more people will know who he is on
sunday
than they did last sunday and uh and now
you get your shot at the title
you actually get it all seems like it's
more important for conor isn't in this
fight
yeah this is a big huge fight for cup
yeah you mentioned you're talking you're
trying to talk to be into coming back
remember when mcgregor retired at one
time too right yeah yeah well what
happens is
you know i'll i'll get these ideas or or
an offer from somebody and
you know as a promoter i have to reach
out and say hey this fight's available
if you want to take it
you know have still one of the best in
the world he's young
and uh you know that
i think there's there's so much more he
could accomplish yeah
dream a dream fight you'd like to see if
you could make match up
right now with your whole stable of
fighters i make dream fights every
weekend
seriously yeah i mean the fights that we
want to see we make this isn't like
boxing where
you know these guys are trying to make a
fight for four or five years
when we want fights and when the fans
want the fights we make them happen
what do you think of the mixed martial
arts guy doing in the boxing thing
or are the celebrities logan paul's and
all these guys yeah like
like i said all the time there's a
market for that and
and it's just a it's a it's a testament
to how busted up
boxing is you know what's sad is you see
these kids that are super talented
you know that are actually really good
and been training their whole life
and uh you know they get no notoriety
whatsoever
and these other people do you got either
youtube famous youtube people fighting
or
50 year old guys i mean it's crazy
but it's it's a testament to how
absolutely screwed up that sport is
final question let me ask you just about
way back when you started you mentioned
that our sport's gonna be bigger than
the nfl
globally he's done a terrific job thanks
yeah and and you know still growing
i mean people people were asking me
yesterday what's the ceiling on this
thing
and i said what i've always been saying
except a lot more stuff is is
real than it was ten years ago it's like
well how many people are in the world
seven billion something like that so
when we started this company right and
we first started doing interviews with
you guys
i had direct tv dish network and
in-demand pay-per-view those are my
three outlets then if i wanted to cut
you know deals in germany or uh italy or
australia
i had to go cut all these separate deals
now with streaming
we're all starting to think about this
in the next 10 to 15 years i believe
that
you and i grew up with nbc cbs abc
there will be three of those but global
you know i don't know who the players
are going to be
um you know could be youtube could be on
netflix imagine if netflix got into
sports with the distribution and things
that they have and when i put on a fight
in the right place at the right time
with the right guys
i could be doing five million
pay-per-view buys every time i
you know when i put on a massive fight i
could do 15 million pay-per-view buys
and the list goes on i mean yeah so when
you talk about
all these other sports right and and how
valuable they are or
aren't when you look at the ufc
and and think about what the potential
is here
there's no other sport like it what's
your biggest challenge
time there's not enough time in the day
to i mean i come in here in the morning
and
feels like i do a few things and then
like it's 6 30
you know what i mean i'm like how the
hell is it 6 30 right now
time is is is the only thing that holds
us back from so much more
uh that i feel we could accomplish in a
day
what's your secret to workout look at
you i'll tell you what the secret is
you know everybody's asking me that the
only thing that i'm doing differently
than i've done in the last 10 years i
hired a trainer
i never had a trainer before so i'd come
in here
do the exercises that i like to do and
never do the ones that i didn't like to
do so when you
it's a game changer hiring a trainer wow
yeah it's
completely changed my life that's great
you look good thanks very much thank you
so much i appreciate that good to see
you
good shot my quick